what's going on everybody and welcome to
a brief channel update on premieres so
if you guys don't know what premieres
are it's just a way for a creator to
pre-record a video and then you can
schedule the premiere or like instantly
premiere it and basically it just starts
like a little countdown and the idea is
that everybody can kind of watch the
video together and there's like a live
chat so it's a lot like a live stream
it's just at least for me the times that
I've tried live-streaming it's actually
really difficult for me to interact with
you guys in the chat because I can
either I can do one or the other I guess
like actually do both I'm sure I can get
better at it but I find it's actually
very difficult to interact with you guys
and livestream at the same time and
that's kind of what turned me off to
live streams so after I had tried doing
live streams I actually thought like wow
how cool would it be to actually just
initially on a video release get the
opportunity to have like a live chat
just for the first few minutes so
everybody could kind of watch it
together and interact and then like it
was like a week later that YouTube
announced this and I was like oh my gosh
that's awesome so first of all I was I
was pretty excited about it because it's
pretty much exactly what I wanted now
there's definitely been some pushback
against it in kind of two forms one is
people that don't like that they show up
in the video can't be played immediately
and then two is people that think
somehow it's gonna like because one
person made a video it sounds like that
they said oh the premieres was the worst
thing ever
and so I watched that guy's video I'm
not gonna put it here but I'm sure
someone could link it below
I honestly forget who it is but I
watched it and he was saying how he got
lots of down votes probably because
people showed up and couldn't watch the
video but he was saying he got like
hundreds of down votes before the video
even went live and then the video itself
performed extremely poorly after it went
live now as I scrolled through his
comments however they were all saying
pretty much the same thing one the video
was too long they just weren't
interested in the content and that kind
of thing so could it be me
the video just wasn't gonna perform well
you know everybody likes to kind of
blame YouTube for their poor performance
but yet you owe everything you owe
you're almost your entire performance of
your YouTube channel to YouTube and
YouTube's algorithms so the fact that
one video didn't perform well could it
be possible that it just was a bad video
or that your viewers just weren't
interested in it I don't know it just
seems like that was the case so there's
that
now the people showing up and leaving
down votes like for example this is a
premiere coming tomorrow I've got 14 up
votes for down votes that like to
dislike ratio is abnormal for my channel
for sure but not abnormal for an initial
release I tend to have a few viewers who
I guess are subscribed and just
instantly downvote when a video goes
live maybe it's like a bot or something
I really don't know but I also can tell
you this I don't care
down votes are basically meaningless so
I thought I was showing this page but
I'm not down votes are basically
meaningless because I don't actually try
to cater to a downvote Pro look at that
I don't actually try to town vote or
cater to down voters there the person
who down votes a video now obviously
some videos deserve down but some of my
videos deserve down votes for sure but
most of time they don't like I remember
I was watching a video like Casey nice
tat a pretty popular vlogger that I'm
sure most you guys know he just released
like a two-minute video to announce that
he just had a kid and just kind of has a
brief channel update and celebration of
a new child and there was like a you
know thousands of people that down voted
that video and I'm like who are those
people right like who is like no mmm
forget about that I don't like that you
know I just don't get it right there's
just a type of person and that person is
not someone I try to cater to generally
I only pay attention to upvotes
how many votes completely irrespective
of the down votes I sometimes I'll look
at the ratio but really it's all about
the number
of upvotes so I just don't care that
much about down votes now obviously the
video gets you know just so some absurd
number of downloads I'll look and see
like what's going on here or something
like that but if somebody comes here and
sees the premiere and can't watch the
video therefore they down vote the video
I mean what I just don't care about you
like if that's your attitude about being
notified and advanced about us videos
schedule like here's when the video is
coming out by the way no I hate that mmm
okay yeah whatever I think it's cool
I really have enjoyed coming to the
premieres I'm you know historically I've
always been there I'm like refreshing
the comment section in chatting with the
people that are here on the video's
release and so the ability for me to now
do that in the live chat it's just
better it's just that's great I really
like that interaction that I'm able to
do so at least in the near term I pull
an to continue launching and doing
premieres basically as soon as the one
video is done if I do have another video
I'm going to release the next day I'm
going to post it as a premiere so the
people that are getting updates about
the premieres I really don't except for
the initial video that you got a
notification for an advanced every time
you receive a notification that means a
video actually was released it's live
right now so to complain about that as
well I I don't know I just seems kind of
silly look like what has changed I just
feel like we're complaining to complain
so anyways I think it's a great update
I'm gonna keep going at it
I like the interactivity as long as
people are there in a live chat and
we're talking and interacting with each
other in the video yeah I think it's a
great update and I haven't noticed any
disincentivizing view numbers if
anything these videos have performed way
better than I actually expected the kind
of an update to the basics videos to
actually have performed and the likes to
dislike ratio also has been like
unbelievable look like I was expecting a
lot of people to be angry at me for
updating a the basic series I have seen
a lot of comments on it
but way less than I expected for people
I expected a lot more people that get up
in arms about me returning back to the
basics and helping other people come
back into Python now because my current
basics are the previous basic series was
really pretty bad it was just getting
really outdated it's not really done the
way I wished it was so anyway that's all
for now if you got questions comments
concerns you think you're I'm gonna kill
my channel with premiers feel free to
let me know down below if I didn't
address your concern about premiers feel
free to leave a comment too but that
seems to kind of encompass the two the
two issues people have been having with
premieres so anyways that's it for now
otherwise I'll see you guys in about 20
hours